[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
offen und herzlich willkommen
freue mich sehr hier zu sein dankeschön
herzlich willkommen
ja in den letzten wochen und monaten
konnte man ja kaum eine zeitung
aufschlagen ohne dass einem das thema
des klimawandels entgegentrat
und meistens auch verbunden mit der
frage was ist eigentlich mit dem
vermehrten flugaufkommen die taten
wahrheit haben sich die flüge in den
nächsten 20 jahren verdoppelt weltweit
gesehen und welche verantwortung haben
eigentlich genau sie und ich angesichts
des klimawandels
über diese fragen wollen die heute am
stammtisch diskutieren und ich freue
mich sehr dass ich meine stammgäste hier
schon sitzen haben hier in basel
ich freue mich sehr dass heute bei uns
ist die politik philosophin aus der
schweiz katja gentinetta
der philosoph konrad paul liessmann aus
wien
unter soziologe harald welzer der aus
berlin zu uns gerecht ist
ja und beim stichwort reisen sind wir
schon mitten im thema und ich frag doch
einfach gleich mal das publikum wer von
ihnen ist denn dieses jahr schon mit dem
flugzeug in die ferien gereist einige
würde ich sagen wer ist aus
geschäftlichen gründen in ein flugzeug
gestiegen bisschen weniger und wer von
ihnen es denn in diesem jahr noch gar
nicht geflogen wo auch einige das jetzt
nicht ganz durchschnitt würde ich sagen
denn auf die ganze schweiz bezogen kann
man festhalten dass im jahr 2016
80 prozent der schweizerinnen und
schweizer mindestens einmal geflogen
sind uns die zahlen nehmen ebenso wie
ist es denn hier am stammtisch
gentinetta fliegen sie jemand in die
vielen sehr selten ist bei uns wirklich
eher die ausnahme der letzte ferienflug
ist auch vier jahre her und den haben
wir als eher umständlich und mühsam
empfunden liegt aber ganz einfach daran
weil unser traum destinationen im
benachbarten frankreich liegen und dafür
ist fliegen ineffizient und sind wenig
sinnvoll
würden sie sagen sie haben da einfach
sozusagen glück gehabt weil ihre
präferenzen so liegen dass sie jetzt
nicht mehr aus um erzieherin hier stehen
oder finden sie hört er auf mit dem wort
umweltsünder eigentlich könnten sie auch
fliegen so viel sie wollen
nein nein ich würde dass er jetzt mal
als glück bezeichnen da es gerade so
passt ist das eigentlich auch ganz gut
geschäftlich gesehen reisen wir ja
wahrscheinlich habe relativ viel also
wenn ich so ihre belegungspläne
anschauen man versucht ein termin mit
ihm nachzumachen kriegt man den eindruck
sie sind ganz schön beschäftigt und
fliegen vermutlich ziemlich viel in der
welt gegen herum
ich habe mich auch gefragt sie beide
haben wir hier ein fliegen müssen für
diesen abend muss ich jetzt ein
schlechtes gewissen haben oder sie weil
sie nicht den zug genommen haben nein ja
dann möchte ich jetzt gerne mal wissen
warum
naja weil sie das zu verantworten haben
sie haben uns eingeladen sie haben uns
sie haben uns das ging aus technischen
gründen nicht weil wir eben geschäftlich
gesehen so viel fliegen müssen dass ich
froh bin wenn ich im sommer eine affäre
nicht fliegen muss
aber sie haben auch das ticket bezahlt
sie haben die fluglinie ausgesucht also
alle die dinge für die ein mensch
verantwortlich zeichnet sie von ihrer
seite getätigt worden also wir sind ja
nur ausführende organe sie hören dem
lachen an so ganz ernst nimmt dass jetzt
aber keiner weiß ich muss ja ich bin
eitel genug dass ich nicht sage oder
sich nicht hätte sagen können liebe
fleisch das ist ein wunderbarer
stammtischen wunderbares thema aber ich
werde sicher nicht in der schweiz
fliegen und für eine zugfahrt habe ich
keine zeit sie müssen ohne nicht
diskutieren das kann ich ihnen doch
nicht antun oder oder ist überhaupt eine
chance
also ich bin schon fasziniert dass er
gerade vom autoritären charakter zum
autonomen subjekt gewechselt ist
innerhalb von 30 sekunden
natürlich ihr seid verantwortlich dafür
ich versuche bei solchen situationen das
immerhin so etwas abzumildern dass ich
versuche viele termine in dieser region
auf diesen diese zwei oder drei auf zwei
oder drei tage zu konzentrieren so dass
wenigstens der flug aufwand auf mehrere
sachen verteilt wird so gehe ich damit
um
und ein problem bleibt es trotzdem ein
problem bleibt es trotzdem bleiben wir
mal kurz bei dieser aussage ist es denn
wirklich ein problem also ist fliegen
ein thema der moral sag ich jetzt mal
drei zentimeter
es ist ganz viel ist ein thema der
moralische und letztlich moral hat ja
auch damit zu tun was ich mache ich muss
wissen was es tun wenn ich weiß wo die
möglichen schäden sind dann kann ich
mich so verhalten
aber dann muss ich sagen okay fliegen
ist moralisch fleisch essen ist und also
ist unmoralisch fleisch essen ist
unmoralisch wenn ich mich überhaupt so
viel bewege ist unmoralisch wenn ich
atme ist unmoralisch wenn wir quasi bei
diesem luftverschmutzung thema sind und
so weiter und so fort am schluss muss
ich sagen der mensch ist unmoralisch
eigentlich die tatsache dass wir da sind
schon unmoralisch und damit sind wir
gehen wir schon recht weit und glaube
ich damit war dann anfang ins detail zu
gehen
also ich finde so zu sagen so weit würde
ich nicht gehen weil man kommt ja nicht
um
da zu sein und das ist ein gewisser
weise auch okay aber sagen wir mal so
wenn man wie vorhin ja auch zitiert von
jahr zu jahr steigende aufwände sieht
egal ob es um das reisen privat um das
reisen beruflich um konsum jeglicher art
oder so was ja dann ist man natürlich
sagen wir mal doch etwas skeptisch
gegenüber so seins äußerungen sondern
wir befinden uns in einem system was
systematisch aufwand erhöht und aus den
unterschiedlichsten gründen sollten wir
damit mit dieser aufwands erhöhung und
was das moralische angeht kann man ja
sagen soll auf einer abstrakten ebene
sind wir jetzt alle ganz moralisch
betroffen dass wir uns falsch verhalten
im rahmen der wirtschafts form in der
wir existieren verhalten wir uns ja hoch
moralisch wir sollen ja immer mehr
kaufen wir sollen immer mehr reisen wir
sollen immer mehr irgendwelche dinge
nehmen und wegschmeißen usw
das heißt die moral diskussion ist er
schon mal völlig abstrahiert von dem was
eigentlich erforderlich ist damit der
laden funktioniert und dass das problem
ob das wirklich das problem ist werden
wir wahrscheinlich nachher gleich noch
weiter diskutieren schaffen die erst mal
fakten und schauen uns die die sachlage
noch einmal genauer an
die einen sagen ja wirklich es ist fünf
vor zwölf wir müssen dringend was tun
die anderen sagen das ist einfach reine
panikmache nachricht ich hab schon
gesagt der flugverkehr der nimmt massiv
zu und trägt zum klimawandel bei
das grounding von alitalia monarch
airlines und air berlin zeigt es
deutlich in der luftfahrtindustrie
herrscht ein gnadenloser preiskampf
nutznießer sind die passagiere wie so
günstig wie noch nie ihre flüge buchen
können
eine der folgen die weltweit
zurückgelegten flugkilometer steigen
beträchtlich an flog 2007 jeder
passagier durchschnittlich 6 183 km
waren es 2014 bereits 860 kilometer was
eine zunahme von 25 prozent entspricht
nachdem sich die mehrheit der menschheit
keinen flug leisten kann bedeutet das
nichts anderes als dass jene die geld
haben immer mehr aufs flugzeug setzen
diesen trend bestätigt auch das
bundesamt für statistik benutzten 2010
drei von fünf schweizern einmal pro jahr
das flugzeug waren es 2015 schon über
vier von fünf im schnitt außerdem zeigt
sich ein weiterer wichtiger trend
während der anteil von geschäftsflügen
in etwa konstant blieb er vor der anteil
von privat und ferienreisen eine starke
steigerung
herr und frau schweizer lassen es sich
gerne gut gehen und sie investieren auch
eine schöne summe um die welt zu sehen
die folgen sind für klimaschützer klar
zunehmende flugverkehr heißt auch zu
nehmendes klimaproblem verließ man
verdrängen die das problem
ich glaube ich dass wir es verdrängen es
ist ja schon seit jahren und mich da zu
sagen jahrzehnten von diesem
klimaveränderungen die rede
die internationalen diskussionen zeigen
dass mit einer einzigen ausnahme alle
wesentlichen staaten alle wesentlichen
führenden politiker der überzeugung sind
dass etwas getan werden muss dass der
co2 ausstoß zurückgefahren werden muss
es werden klima konferenzen abgehalten
es wäre ein klima ziele vorgegeben
werden diskutiert und man erreicht sie
einfach nicht und das hat schon auch
damit zu tun was er will so gesagt hat
dass wir in einer widersprüchlichen
situation sind dass wir auf der einen
seite natürlich das interesse daran
haben können ich weiß gar nicht ob das
ein moralisches problem ist
klimaveränderungen zusammen zu stoppen
oder zu reduzieren und auf der anderen
seite uns ein lebensstil nahe gelegt
wird und so imperativ nahegelegt wird
der genau zu diesen negativen
konsequenzen auch führt was die moral
betrifft denke ich haben wir das große
problem was mich als philosophen
natürlich besonders interessiert es gilt
eine philosophie seit kans oder
grundsatz also das was ich tue und was
gut ist einer guten maxime folgt muss
universalisierung sein und ist dann gut
für alle
und bei diesen aktivitäten die das klima
negativ beeinflussen haben wir das
paradoxe problem dass man sagen kann
würde nur ich es tun hätten wir gar kein
problem
ja also wenn nur ich hin und wieder
fliegen dann gibt es keine
klimakatastrophe kann klimawandel ist
überhaupt kein thema aber das wird erst
dann zum thema wenn das was an sich für
mich gut ist was für die kommunikation
gut ist was er die wissenschaft gut ist
was wir meine bildung gut die ist
nämlich fernreisen was eine
interkulturelle austausch gut ist
nämlich fremde länder besuchen also
alles das ideale unseres aufgeklärten
europa ausmachen wird plötzlich zum
problem wenn ich genau das
was ebenfalls zu diese idealen gehört
was ich als gut empfinden sollen alle
anderen auch tun können und wenn dies
tun dann wird das ach so gute plötzlich
zum ganz ganz bösen und das muss man
erst einmal verkraften
jetzt sagen sie verkauft die vornehmlich
gerade fragen und wie lösen wir dass sie
wollen sie erst mal einfach verkauft
ich glaube nicht dass wir das lösen kann
indem wir das tatsächlich in einem
individuellen sinn moral ist also
moralisiert werde das ist sozusagen kein
moralisches problem sondern ein
ökonomisches problem technisches problem
wir leben im kapitalismus und ich bin
dafür die probleme des kapitalismus und
kapitalismus zu lösen er kann einfach
problemfach über preise wahrscheinlich
deshalb bin ich auch über diesen begriff
moralisch gestolpert für mich also
moralisch wenn wir ein moralisches
problem haben hilfe das ja wir müssen
uns gegen gegenüber der natur moralisch
verhalten weil wir die natur als solchen
halten das rennen wären
das ist das problem das problem ist wir
müssen uns vor allem verhalten gegenüber
unseren nachkommen generationen nicht
der natur gegenüber
die natur ist uns ganz egal und wie es
in der natur ganz gut da könnte man ja
noch unterschiedliche perspektiven
einwenden dass man kann sagen die natur
hat man sich einen wert oder die
zukünftigen generationen oder bei einer
kandidatur verschwindet ja nicht nur
weil es um zwei grad wärmer wird das war
vor 500 jahren war es auch um zwei grad
wärmer vor 2000 jahren
denn je in der schweiz keinen einzigen
gletscher ja deshalb meinen ist werde
ich eben auch nicht als moralisches
problem anschauen sondern wirklich als
politisches und ökonomisches problem
wenn wir zu viel fliegen und wenn wir
wissen dass fliegen die und die effekte
hat dann müssen wir uns überlegen wie
können wir diese effekte eindämmen
und da gibt es verschiedene maßnahmen
man kann dass sie beim preis machen muss
kann man kann ist über kontingente man
machen man kann es über regulierung
machen und so weiter und so fort
aber es sind alles allesamt keine
moralischen appelle beziehungsweise
glaube ich dass moralische appelle
allein nicht genügen sonst hätten wir
nicht diese plus 25 prozentige hätten im
wissen darum dass fliegen schädlich ist
das hier ja bedeuten und dass vier von
fünf schweizern böse sehen
das wollen wir nicht glauben kann
möglich sei aber dass das grundsätzliche
was damit ja auch angesprochen ist und
das ist ja gesellschaftlich betrachtet
eigentlich der große trick
ist es das problem individualisiert wird
im sinne dessen dass leute sich schuldig
fühlen sollen wenn sie das tun was sie
andererseits tun sollen
das heißt eigentlich werden die
soziologen würden sagen die
gesellschaftlichen strukturen und die
wirtschaftlichen erfordernisse
ausgeblendet man konstatiert das problem
existiert und ihr bitte sollte jetzt
alle ein schlechtes gewissen haben weil
ihr diesem imperativ volk das ist die
paradoxie ja und insofern hat man es
weniger mit einem moralischen als mit
einem politischen problemen zu tun weil
ein wesensmerkmal unserer gesellschaft
ja das ist dass das immer weitergehen
soll und alles das was folge davon ist
entweder nach außen abgewendet wird
extern avisiert wird oder in inneres
schulz verhältnis umgekehrt wird und das
ist natürlich das nimmt die politische
spannung aus der sache raus geht es
nicht ein bisschen billig einfach zu
sagen na ja so ein politisches problem
dann sie gegen die auch alle fein raus
schauen wie politiker mal was machen ich
würde dich sagen dass man deshalb fein
raus ist weil als individuum hat man
natürlich die verantwortung die probleme
zur kenntnis zu nehmen und nach den
möglichkeiten die man hat in irgendeiner
weise das eigene verhalten zu verändern
also bei günther anders hieß das
moralische gymnastik man kann sich in
etwas einüben was am erst schwer fällt
es kommt ja noch was dazu fliegen ist ja
ätzend also es ist ja nicht so dass das
irgendwie super natürlich nicht ich
glaube eigentlich finden es alle sie
glauben nur das gehört irgendwie dazu
dass man das tut und ich glaube es gibt
eine kommunikative ebene wo das alles
toll ist ja fliegen reisen da und da hin
und insgeheim glauben glück glaube ich
dass ganz viele menschen gibt die sagen
ach ich würde echt viel lieber zu hause
bleiben und fernsehen
ich frage mich manchmal einfach ob die
ganze debatte oder die unsicherheit wie
man benennen so ein moralisches problem
politisches problem ob das nicht doch
auch noch etwas damit zu tun hat dass
man unsicher ist wie gravierend der
flugverkehr wirklich ist mit blick auf
den klimawandel weil natürlich das auto
ganz unterschiedliche meinungen
kursieren und da habe
auch unterschiedliche meinungen dem
publikum und ich gebe zu ein paar
experten die wir eingeladen haben um ein
bisschen diesen fakten check zu machen
hier bei mir ist zum einen philipp neri
vom wwf
wie schätzen sie die situation ein darf
man noch fliegen und wie schlimm ist
denn das fliegen tatsächlich also zur
frage wie schlimm ist es die schweiz
wird ein offizielles
treibhausgasinventar da kann man nach
gucken was so welche ursache hatten
sieht man fliegen sind 18 prozent heute
also ein sehr relevanter anteil dafür
dass es im leben nicht die bedeutung hat
vielleicht wie mit dem auto zur arbeit
fahren oder die wohnung zu heißt also 18
prozent des co2 ausstoßes genau heizen
und straßenverkehr das ist noch mit mehr
budget runter teilweise sehr stark beim
fliegen geht es einfach weiter weiter im
steigflug der und beim thema zu bleiben
also so gesehen scheint mir echt die
sachlage rechtler 18 prozent und darf
man noch fliegen ihrer meinung nach
ich wäre schon froh wenn wir die frage
gestellt werden muss man wirklich so
viel fliegen wie viel glücklicher macht
zu uns weil wir ja schon wie zum
beispiel schon deutsche österreicher die
fliegen halb so viel wie wir schweizer
schnitt sind deswegen weniger glücklich
oder sind sie überhaupt weniger
glücklich ich bezweifle dass es wäre
schon mannschaft da in diese richtung
wissen zu denken sie sprechen das anders
die schweizer auffallend viele fliegen
sind in europa glaube ich spitzenreiter
gibt unterschiedliche begründungen dafür
unter anderem natürlich auch der relativ
hohen wohlstandsniveau in der schweiz
ich bin bei einer neuen person nämlich
bei paul cousins präsident von
flugverband aerofreeze und war sehr sehr
viele jahre auch selber pilot wie
schätzen sie es sein wahrscheinliches
fliegen also jede menschliche aktivität
verursacht eine belastung der umwelt ab
es ist nun wirklich nicht so wie es
immer wieder kolportiert wird das
fliegen dass man ein schlechtes gewissen
haben muss beim fliegen ich möchte ihnen
ein paar zahlen nennen
zum einen die luftfahrt die weltweite
luftfahrt ist lediglich zu zwei prozent
am globalen menschengemachten co2
ausstoß beteiligt wenn man jetzt noch
die anderen schadstoffe dazurechnen
dann kommt man und das habe nicht ich
selber auf uns und das tram 23 bis ich
sie auf einen anteil von ungefähr 3,5
prozent den die luftfahrt am
menschengemachten treibhauseffekt
beiträgt
nun können sie sagen ja aber das
wachstum ist so schlimm das haben wir
vor ihnen auch gehört ich muss ihnen
sagen
das wachstum findet statt das ist
zwangsläufig aber die emission steigt
nicht im gleichen maß die luft tagen
haben die zahl gehört von 18
das ist nicht richtig es ist so dass in
der schweiz
hier sind wir jetzt seien bis in einem
zahlensalat werden ein viertel des für
die für den transportsektor
ausgestellten treibstoff für die
luftfahrt gebraucht also kann es nicht
18 prozent des gesamten umsatzes seien
aber vielleicht noch ein wort die luft
hat nimmt ihre verantwortung gebe um
wald umwelt wahr und hat als erster
sektor weltweit überhaupt im rahmen der
uno ein abkommen das sogenannte
kursieren abkommen beschlossen dass die
co2 emissionen der luftfahrt begrenzt
das ist beispielhaft und schon aus
diesen gründen muss ich sagen müssen sie
kein schlechtes gewissen haben wenn sie
fliegen im übrigen die moralische
absolution sozusagen möchte trotzdem
vielleicht noch ganz kurz die
möglichkeit geben zu erwidern weil die
zahlen jetzt doch sehr stark
auseinanderklaffen genau also wie gesagt
ich beziehe mich auf offizielle bauen
treibhausgasinventar sowie ist
wasserdicht
das andere wegen quasi soll man
schlechtes gewissen habe ich meine was
iris problem ist man vergnügt sich eine
kosten anderer leute weil für quasi die
folgen des klimawandels die man hier den
man hier beschleunigt kommt man ja nicht
auf ausflug passagier und hier müssen
wir vielleicht auch so wenn man
diskutiert dieses moralische oder nicht
muss man sich erst einmal ansetzen und
der punkte in korea das ist würde ich
jetzt dazu
lehrstück in sachen green washing
bezeichnet es für das vom
internationalen abgesprochen wurde
vielleicht laufen wir doch noch ganz
kurz war das doch sehr ins detail jetzt
geht wir gehen noch kurz zu florian eckl
er ist ökonom und vizepräsident des
think tanks voraus und er schreibt seine
doktorarbeit an der eth zum thema
finanzierung und klimawandel
sie haben das jetzt gehört diese
unterschiedlichen zahlen
sie beschäftigen sich sozusagen ihren
studien damit wie kommt dazu und was
würden sie jetzt sagen wenn ich sie auf
schiedsrichter einsetzen würde genauso
guten abend zuerst schiedsrichter das
vielleicht ein bisschen weit gegriffen
aber die differenz mit frauen daher dass
wir gehen beim treibhausgasinventar von
einem seil aus die einfach das co2 an
und für sich ist und das ist gut zehn
prozent des ausstoßes co2 ausstoß in der
schweiz und jetzt geht es darum ob
flugzeuge stoßen auch andere sachen aus
zum beispiel für rußpartikel die einen
erwärmung effekte und jetzt geht es
darum die rechnet man das um wieder auf
diese größe co2 weil wir in dieser größe
rechnen
und jetzt gibt es verschiedene studien
die verschiedenes zu diesem
umrechnungsfaktor sagen was wir sorgen
kann ist er mir dass das absolut ist
entnehmen sind wir bei ungefähr 15
prozent also wir sind sehr nahe und
diesen 18 ich würde das als eine obere
grenze an bezeichnen aber wir sind
sicher sehr weit weg von den zwei
prozent und was relevant ist wenn wir
hier diskutieren ist die schweiz weil es
sind unsere entscheidungen und es ist
die schweizerin und der schweizer der
diese entscheidung macht und darum ist
ein globaler zahlenmäßig aussagekräftig
würde ich sagen dann vielleicht noch
ganz kurz würden sie sagen man darf noch
fliegen oder was es daher antwort
man darf liegen aber man so wenig wie
möglich fliegen ich würde nicht sagen es
ist absolut verboten zu fliegen weil ich
sehr es gibt ganz viele andere
das meine ich bin vizepräsident eines
außenpolitischen thinktanks ganz viele
verhandlungen in eine in nordkorea krise
oder stellen sie sich vor didier
burkhalter hätten nicht in die ukraine
fliegen können aber sehr osze präsident
war also das fliegen hat auch andere
werte in der gesellschaft aber wir
müssen es zurückfahren auf die kommen
dann vielleicht auch gleich noch zu
sprechen
ich würde gerne an dieser stelle einfach
mal sagen wir haben so was wie einen
expertenstreit
und interessant finde ich die frage was
machen eigentlich philosophen wenn sie
einen expertenstreit gibt kann man sich
dann zurücklehnen und sagen die sind
sicher nicht einigen können unter
weiterfliegen
mich interessiert philosophisch dahinter
natürlich ganz was anderes nicht ob das
jetzt ein 15 prozent sind also das 18
prozent sehen die der flugverkehr auf
sich zieht sondern die strategie der
abwälzung auf von verantwortung
denn wenn man sagt okay also nur 15
prozent flugverkehr was ist ein
autoverkehr dass sie vielleicht zwölf
prozent der oder 20 prozent
was ist mit industrieabgasen ja das sind
vielleicht 30 prozent oder geht es um
arbeitsplätze da kann man schon gar
nicht eingreifen
der flugverkehr jetzt immerhin
hauptsächlich und gehört und
freizeitverhalten das kann man doch viel
leichter reduzieren als arbeitsplätze
vernichten und sozusagen kann man immer
von einem eck ins andere die
verantwortung abschieben philosophisch
interessant also dann wo ist eigentlich
die verantwortung wer trägt sie genau
wie gesagt wurde also wie lokalisierbar
ist sie eigentlich und das zweite oder
wenn vielleicht noch dazu kommen denke
ich dass dieses verhalten ja nicht
spontan aus den menschen erwächst
sondern natürlichen verhalten ist dass
sie einen bestimmten konzepten an
bestimmten präferenzen und an bestimmten
vorgaben orientiert und wir haben eben
seit 200 jahren mobilität fixiert auf
allen ebenen und das wirklich so fisch
diskutieren wollte und nicht um
prozentzahlen streiten will oder um
technologische mögliche möglichkeiten
das ein bisschen zu reduzieren
treibstoff ausstoß ein bisschen zu
reduzieren durch bessere motoren oder e
mobilität für flugzeuge irgendjemand
wird auf diese idee kommen immer das
nicht auf den tisch neben diskutieren
wollen müssen wir überhaupt einmal
hinterfragen dieses mobilitätskonzept ja
es steht ja auch nirgendwo geschrieben
dass sich kreuz und curlern erdball zu
bewegen an sich im wert sein soll
man kann ja genau so die these vertreten
es wäre besser gerade doch in dem sinne
der philosophie der leute wie ein so wie
kant in königsberg bleiben akku game und
mal ordentlich nachdenken dann kommen
solche
das wird ihnen wahrscheinlich in die
karten oder ja tatsächlich ist es so
dass eben diese diese oder andersrum
nochmal gesagt um das zu ergänzen zu den
ungelösten rätsel der menschheit gehört
ja dass kommunikation immer besser wird
ja das ist ja auch die ganze reklame der
digitalwirtschaft und alles das
kommunikation
erstaunlicherweise obwohl die leute
eigentlich fern kommunikation in einer
ungeahnten perfektion und konferenzen
und alles mögliche machen könnten ohne
sich zu bewegen bewegen sie sich immer
mehr
das heißt hier ist noch mal ein beispiel
für diese permanente aufwands erhöhung
und ich finde diese position ich würde
dir ja auch vertreten ich komme ja gott
sei dank auch aus einer stadt die als
einzige weltmetropole intensiv daran
arbeitet keinen flughafen
[Gelächter]
da kann man schon auch sehen dass man
auf der struktur ebene viel tun kann
wenn man intensiv dran bleibt aber
tatsächlich ist es die frage das sind
alles gewissermaßen als
selbstverständlich vorausgesetzt grund
gegebenheiten unserer existenz man muss
mobil sein man muss noch mobiler sein
man muss alles gesehen haben und so
weiter und so weiter
ohne dass überhaupt die frage gestellt
wird wir fangen ja immer am ende an zu
diskutieren ist es mit dem flugzeug
irgendwie ich glaube die frage ist total
präzise formuliert warum bleiben nicht
die leute einfach zu hause wenn ich
ihnen beiden zuhöre dann habe ich so
viel unser alltag besteht aus lauter
zwang weil man sich bewegen muss bewegt
man sich weil man mobil sein muss ist
man mobil weinmann konsumieren muss
konsumiert man das glaube ich einfach
nicht ich glaube viele menschen wollen
gerne reisen sie wollen gerne
kommentieren
sie wollen mobil sein sie wollen sich in
der welt bewegen und das quasi als zwang
zu unterstellen finde ich finde ich
etwas weit gegriffen
das schöne am expertenstreit ist dass
die experten schreibt eigentlich das
nette wort oder das gepflegte wort für
den zahlensalat es den wir gehört haben
oder und das macht man mit einem salat
man pickt sich gerne das rauslassen
gerne hätte die rucola blätter oder die
die petersilie oder die radieschen oder
was auch immer und philosophischer der
politik philosophisch würde ich eben
sagen wir haben jetzt diesen salat
und die frage ist wie einigen wir uns
als gesellschaft in einer demokratie
darauf wie wir mit diesen salatteller
umgehen wollen wir sozusagen einzelne
elemente daraus präferieren oder wollen
wir sagen wir wissen dass die
beschiedenen dinge auf diesen
salatteller schädlicher sind weniger
schädlich sind besser sind gierig aber
ihr rechnen wenn sie von wo da wäre
jedes salatblatt auf dem teller platz
haben können es gibt ja wahrscheinlich
schon auch zahlen die da nicht
hingehören würden ja das ist ja das ist
ja noch ein ganz anderes problem in
diesem thema finde ich meine wir sind
philosophisch gebildet um das zu
verstehen und dem folgen zu können
gehört noch mal ein gehörige portion
naturwissenschaftliches wissen dazu oder
eine eine unendliche mühe sich durch all
diese blätter und fakten und zahlen aber
durch sich am schluss muss ich
irgendeinem vertrauen muss ich gewissen
leuten vertrauen sagen entweder vertraut
im bauch oder den wwf oder wem auch
immer irgendwo muss ich mich fahren
können und dann meine entscheidung für
mich fällen können da bin ich ganz bei
ihnen einverstanden
aber dann möchte ich ein stück freiheit
haben die da aber dass das kriterium
diese entscheidung zu fällen ist doch
eine vollkommen andere ist ein anderes
kriterium so ähnlich wie er ließ man das
eben ja auch schon gesagt hat die die
fakten sind doch völlig evident
grundsätzlich und zwar seit 40 jahren ja
dass wir ein problem haben was das
klimasystem an geht es wie ein problem
haben was biodiversität angeht dass wir
ein problem haben was die ozeane angeht
etc
totaler konsens in der wissenschaft und
alle kurven zeigen nach oben was das
angeht und gleichzeitig tut man dann
gewissermaßen künstlich naiv so als gäbe
es dann noch unklarheit in bestimmten
zahlen nach dem färben und gerade ja
aber das eher irrelevant
an der stelle ist das ja total weil das
grundsätzliche problem vollkommen
evident es wir betreiben eine form von
wirtschaft und eine form von
lebensstilen die sich übrigens seit
einiger zeit globalisiert
verhängnisvoller weise globalisiert
kommt noch sozusagen dazu und sehen das
was der fall ist entweder auf den
diagrammen der einschlägigen kolleginnen
und
kollegen aus der wissenschaft oder auch
sehr handfest also sei es durch
extremwetterereignisse sei es durch
verstärkte migration alle diese sachen
sind total sichtbar und das hat nichts
damit zu tun ob es nun 16 oder 18
prozent sind was der flugverkehr dazu
beiträgt so und ich würde sagen diese
form der kleinteiligen diskussion gehört
gewissermaßen zur ideologischen deck
geschichte die man sich erzählt wir sind
ja alle sehr besorgt ich weiß dass die
flug wirtschaft total besorgt ist die
autoindustrie ist auch total besorgt die
bauwirtschaft ist auch besorgt alle sind
total besorgt
aber die fakten also zu sagen die
basalen fakten dass wir eine form von
lebenspraxis kultivieren die nicht
tragfähig ist für das 21 jahrhundert
dass er ganz basale simple geschichte
und der kammern braucht man auch nicht
studiert haben um das zu verstehen an
der diskutieren wir großartig es vorbei
wäre sozusagen der vorwurf dass wir den
der vorwurf dass sie haben schon aus
prinzip der verantwortung dauern
verletzen oder hier wir verhindern
eigentlich dass wir so handeln dass wir
eine welt schaffen in der auch
nachkommende generationen noch gut leben
können aber das irgendwie sagen dass das
geht nicht und das ist es was wir machen
jetzt noch mal um auf den salatteller
zurückzukommen ich meine das fliegen ist
ein aspekt ich habe am einleiten gesagt
fleisch essen ist ein anderes als ein
anderer aspekt kinder ist ein noch
weiterer aspekt die bevölkerungs und so
weiter und so fort und da ist es eben im
detail dann schon ein bisschen
entscheidend dass wir wissen was
wirklich wie viel verursacht und nutze
überlegen welche maßnahmen ergreifen
wird damit sie auch effizient sind und
nicht nur moralisch heute dass ich halte
das für eine scheindiskussion man könnte
die diskussion ganz anders führen und
sagen schweizer haben eine nacht mal
hören carbon footprint als leute aus
mali oder sonst was er schon 20 mal
hören was fangen wir damit an dann
machen wir jetzt präferenzen ob du ein
bisschen weniger fliegen und dafür
bisher mehr suv oder so was uns in
irgendeiner weise in einer eine
vernünftige position bringt das problem
ist dass die reichen gesellschaften in
denen wir das privileg haben zu leben
erst mal die verursacher dieser global
sich zeigenden probleme sind das muss
man doch mal ernst nehmen und deshalb
zeitlich aber unter beweis gestellt
haben um andere themen zu nehmen
beispielsweise luftverschmutzung weise
wasserverschmutzung beispielsweise
biodiversität das in den letzten 20
jahren da auch schon viele fortschritte
erzielt worden sind gekommen haben
produktion nach china ausgelagert ganz
hervorragend nicht und nicht nur das das
eine produktion nach china ausgelagert
haben wir haben ja auch anstatt die
konsequenz zu ziehen und unsere
lebensform zu verändern oder
einzuschränken oder andere gewichtungen
zu setzen haben es hier exportiert ja
das heißt also wir haben ja alles getan
damit die chinesen die in den 60er
jahren noch ein volk von radfahrern
waren zu einem volk von autofahrern
wären mit all denen einhergehenden
problemen und moralisch kann man da gar
nichts dagegen sagen ja wir fahren gern
auto wir fliegen gerne warum soll das
anderen menschen vorenthalten bleiben
dass er der lebensstil denn wie auch
global als genau dieses ihn als wertvoll
und als erstrebenswerte das
nachahmenswerte plakatieren und
praktizieren und propagieren ich wollte
nur zur freiheit etwas sagen denn er
scheint mit philosophisch natürlich das
wesentliche und interessanter zu sein
ich habe nie gesagt dass wir unter zwang
hunt und ja das wäre unsinn ist mich
zwingt niemand mit fördert eine pistole
noch in der schweiz zu fliegen
das habe wohl das sind in der fabrik
durchaus zutrauen würde für eine gute
sendung muss man schon fast alles machen
ja aber kein mensch handelt der
wirklichen dem sind autonom dass er
vollkommen unbeeinflusst ist und der
welt in der er lebt von den
rahmenbedingungen dieser welt vor allem
von den preisen die in dieser welt
herrschen so lange fliegen relativ teuer
waren haben menschenverächter von
getreuen vielleicht nicht einmal davon
geträumt aber es sind nicht geflogen
jetzt wird es in den operiert jetzt
werden diese wünsche natürlich
christlich angestachelt auch und
natürlich stoße sie danach auf ein
bedürfnis hat eine sehnsucht die man
glaubt auf diese art und weise
befriedigen zu können und um dann zu
sagen aber du bist schon jetzt allein
dafür verantwortlich da kannst du jetzt
frei entscheiden und du kannst auch das
leben eines außenseiters führen der
verachtet wird weil er noch nie dort war
weil er noch nie in china war weil er
sie für fremde kulturen nicht
interessiert dann ist er ohnehin gleich
rechtsradikal ja also ich würd ich würde
gerne sie noch fragen er wählt soll sie
haben jetzt mehr mal gesagt na ja der
ganze lebensstil ist eine art und weise
kann vielleicht haben angeschwollen oder
auch niveau hatten niveau erreicht dass
es einfach nicht mehr zu machen ist ist
er trägt unseren planet erträgt das so
einfach nicht mehr
nun hat zum beispiel der wwf tatsächlich
gesagt wenn wir den ökologischen
fußabdruck anschauen
ein guter vorschlag wer doch dass ihr
alle einfach weniger arbeiten da nämlich
weniger verdient denn jedoch weniger
konsumieren
also das wäre sozusagen ein vorschlag
den sie vermutlich unterstützen werden
na ja nicht konsumieren es schwierig
weil von irgendwas wird man sich
ernähren müssen man wird auch was
trinken müssen und so weiter und so
weiter leben besteht in stoff umwandlung
und insofern führt man sich was zu und
gibt auch wieder was ab die frage ist ja
ist ja eine weit aufgefächert
frage ich glaube dass eigentlich die
möglichkeiten in einem 21 jahrhundert
eine auskömmliche ist und vielleicht
auch von den beziehungen her und so
weiter gutes leben zu führen sicherlich
erstmal für die reichen gesellschaften
aber auch global besser sind als ich
jemals zuvor gewesen sind womit sich
automatisch die frage stellt wird es
denn verbessert und auch überhaupt
erreicht durch die ständige steigerungs
logik oder wodurch wie würde ich das
jetzt nutzen vorhin das beispiel mit wir
haben wesentlich verbesserte
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
dann muss ich auch so wissenschaftler
als wissenschaftler nicht zu jedem
debatten workshop irgendwie nach
südamerika fliegen das kann ich doch
über skype erledigen ich fliege sowieso
ich mache das kann ich jetzt mal hier
als sozusagen heiliger und minderer die
miete gleich einigen scheinen ja
fernreisen mache ich nicht so und weil
ich tatsächlich findet dass das was man
dort auf diese weise erledigen kann per
skype oder video-konferenz oder so wird
es reicht völlig aus weil das geheimnis
dabei ist ja dass sich in wahrheit die
leute auch gar nicht so gerne treffen
sondern froh sind wenn das business
erledigt ist und vielleicht das mit der
bahre abends das ist gut aber die
eigentlich der ganze bohei der gemacht
wird der ist ja nicht wirklich
erstrebenswert
jetzt möchte ich gerne von frau
zentimeter wissen das ja eigentlich eine
wachstumskritik ein stück weit nämlich
ein stück weit substanzielle
wachstumskritik v zentimeter was sagen
sie dazu
ein großes thema und natürlich könnte
ich mich jetzt hier als wachstums
befürworterin ausspielen was man von mir
auch ganz genau erwartet in dem punkt
würde ich ihnen ganz klar sagen das was
sie ansprechen ist ja etwas was sich
gerade in unserer gesellschaft jetzt
bemerkbar macht das viel mehr leute
sagen ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht
mehr so weit weg ich möchte gar nicht
mehr so viel konsumieren
ich gehe lieber schönherz spaziergang
machen ich bleibe lieber in meiner
bibliothek geht mir übrigens auch so
also all diese dinge all dies lässt
weniger ruhiger nicht mehr so viel das
ist eigentlich ganz schön verbreitet und
verbreitet aber seinen fliegen jährlich
aber da hätte ich noch eine andere these
ist aber auch ein punkt stands phänomen
mit anderen worten aufstrebenden
gesellschaften wie wir jetzt in asien
sehen die wollen natürlich erstmal den
mittelstand erreichen und sie wollen den
mittelstand weiter führen damit es ihre
kinder noch mal besser haben und erst
wenn diese gesellschaft und wenn viele
von diesen gesellschaften in diesen
gesellschaften den start erreicht haben
sind wir haben werden sie vermutlich auf
ähnliche gedanken kommen nur sie aber
nur her drauf kommen oder sie kommen
schneller drauf weil sie unser beispiel
haben lebens auch gut aber ich würde das
nicht an sich verteufeln beziehungsweise
ich würde das den anderen nicht einfach
es gibt aber im moment also zwei sätze
dazu wir können es denen gar nicht
absprechen weil das steht überhaupt
nicht in unserem mandat
ja das ist kann man jetzt irgendwie
stundenlang darüber erzählen aber es ist
deren angelegenheit wie sie ihr leben
gestalten punkt 1.2 ist das so etwas wie
die eben die die entstehung von
mittelklassen und sowas ja nicht nur
eine rein materielle angelegenheit ist
sie haben es ja selber gesagt wer nicht
lebenschancen für meine kinder oder
meine enkelkinder imaginären kann die
vorher nie hatte wenn ein wanderarbeiter
in china nicht davon ausgehen muss mehr
dass seine kinder auch wanderarbeiter
werden das ist eine immaterielle
qualität dessen die gesellschaften sich
entwickeln das hat aber nichts damit zu
tun ob man irgendwie auch immer als juli
kriegen kann die aber in der regel über
wachstum läuft muss man einfach schon
konkret an dieser stelle eine andere
stimme noch einbringen und zwar den
umweltaktivisten al gore er war ja
berühmt dafür immer sehr kritisch zu
sein und auch pessimistisch zu sein hat
eine kehrtwende gemacht sein neuester
film ist sehr optimistisch und mein
kollege ich post hat mit al gore letzte
woche gesprochen
ein berühmter ökonomen der verstorbenen
rudi dornbusch sagte einmal bis etwas
passiert geht es länger als man denkt
dann aber passiert das viel schneller
als man es für möglich gehalten hätte
und diese art von exponentielle
veränderung wir kennen das aus dem
bereich der technologie mit dem burschen
gesetz mobiltelefonen und vielen anderen
gerät
es ist sehr spannend dass dieses gleiche
muster jetzt bei erneuerbaren energien
auftaucht bei der led beleuchtung bei
elektrofahrzeugen batterien bei
tausenden neuer technologien
die welt befindet sich gerade im frühen
stadium einer globalen
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ermöglicht
durch digitale werkzeuge wie die
künstliche intelligenz das internet der
dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
die entscheidende frage ist wie schnell
wir sie lösen werden und dass wir darauf
vertrauen können den point of no return
nicht zu überschreiten
also das ist was hier verkündet wurde es
ist sozusagen die neue globale ideologie
wir haben probleme aber die
digitalisierung lösen also die
digitalisierung erscheint jetzt auf
allen ebenen als der problemlöser
schlechthin ob das jetzt bildung ist ob
das forschung ist auch dass
kindererziehung ist ob das eben
der klimawandel ist daran ist immer ein
bisschen etwas war wie schon gesagt
wurde digitalisierung möglichst formen
von kommunikation ermöglicht
effizienteres produzieren ermöglicht
sparsamen umgang mit energie ganz klar
und daran ist auch vieles dann nicht
richtig weil die hoffnungen überzogen
sind weil auch digitalisierungsprozess
kostenintensiv sehen energieintensiv
sind ganze reihe von problemen etwa
ganze batterien ja kein mensch weiß
entsorgt werden sollen ja auftauchen die
ebenfalls jetzt mal in der ersten
euphorie ausgeblendet werden und dann
kommt noch etwas dazu da denke jetzt
schon die ganze zeit darüber nach was ja
welcher gesagt hat warum zu sagen so
wenig diese möglichkeiten wieder
konferenzen über skype abzuhalten
genutzt werden ich glaube es gibt schon
auch so etwas wie verstellbare und
legitime bedürfnisse von menschen die
vielleicht nicht immer sehr laut das
sind ja die mühlen vielleicht gar nichts
gerne zu diesen konferenzen fahren aber
es kann sein dass alle ziemlich froh
sind wenn sie nicht zu hause sein
das heißt man muss mal drüber überlegen
aber nachdenken also warum schaffen wir
die welt die umwelt die unmittelbare
umwelt in der wir leben so dass wir alle
weg wollen also das eine
da könnt ihr auch darüber nachdenken und
das zweite werk ist umwelt so dass jeder
wirklich ganz ganz gerne zu haus wäre
dann würden alle zur verfügung er nicht
mehr funktionieren und das zweite ist
ich gerade heute auch das
digitalisierung modell von kommunikation
und offeriert das auf dauer
unbefriedigend ist es gibt einfach
nichts schöneres als reale situationen
mit realen menschen und realen
kommunikationen und sogar wenn sie
wieder fertig sind ist das interessanter
als der erscheint auf einem bildschirm
und die clips sind einfach auswählen
nicht mehr diskutieren will also offen
sich die haben wir hier auch ein
bedürfnis danach diese formen von
sozialer interaktion zu leben und nicht
zu delegieren digitale oder nicht nur zu
delegieren delikt digitale medien zu
einem großteil machen wir sie ohnehin
keinen vielen optimismus verlage absolut
nicht zumal diese ganze reklame der
digitalisierung wie wunderbar problem
lösen sie ist ja einfach mal von der
schlichten tatsache absieht dass sie
eigentlich nur die fortsetzung unserer
ganz konventionellen fossilen
kultur mit mitteln einer digitalen
beschleunigung ist ist muss sich ja nur
angucken wie viel mehr pakete durch die
welt wandern wie viel mehr produkte
gekauft werden wie kürzer die
produktzyklen werden und so weiter um
mal dieses ganze dieses schöne märchen
der diskussion oder so was mal in frage
zu stellen da ist überhaupt nichts dran
disruptive es wird schneller von
einsicht diese option dass er das was
digitalwirtschaft immer sagt sie machen
schaffen irgendwie ganz neue form der
konsumtion ganz neue formen des
zusammenlebens der und diese ganze
problemlösungs erzählung ja wir schaffen
alle krankheiten ab und soja dieses ist
nicht destruktiv dran und übrigens
worüber bei der digitalisierung nie
gesprochen wird ist wenn man den stecker
rauszieht ist over das heißt es ist eine
dumme technologie in dem sinne als sie
selber völlig abhängig ist und sie ist
nicht destruktiv wir haben im übergang
der den satz bitte noch im übergang der
industrialisierung in ein neues regime
ist ein neues energie regime von also
zur fossilen energie hin
gesellschaftliche modernisierung hat
immer was mit unterschiedlichen energie
regime zu tun das ist konventionell
kalter kaffee diese digitalisierung auch
wenn alle immer das gegenteil behaupten
ich glaube al gores tun dies natürlich
dass wir vor allem an einem übergang
sind zu erneuerbaren energien und ich
würde an dieser stelle gerne noch einmal
zu florian täglich gehen und ihn fragen
wie ihr den den optimismus von al gore 1
respektive können wir davon ausgehen
dass sich die sache von selber lösen
wird und wird irgendwann auch die
möglichkeit geben von sagen die man
grünen flugzeugen oder sagt dass ein
teil der sache wird sich von selber
lösen und nämlich die sache also von
selber lösen ist ein schlechtes wort
aber wird sich oder ist lösbar nämlich
die der stromproduktion
sie seien heute schon dass das
solarstrom kostet einen bruchteil dessen
was zum beispiel england für hinkley
point als wir ihr neues atomkraftwerk
ausgegeben haben
also es ist die billigste energie vom
die die menschheit je gesehen hat ist
jetzt schon so lange die das sehen wir
und das wird sich auch durchsetzen und
ich glaube darauf spielt er goran das
wird sich aber nicht im flugverkehr
durchsetzen und darum es wird immer
bereiche geben unsere wirtschaft unseres
lebens
die nicht in den mystischen frist
dekarbonisierung können die wir nicht in
den nächsten 30 40 jahren
dekarbonisierung können darum optimismus
ja aber es ist auch ganz wichtig zu
sehen was steht am anfang dieser
optimismus am anfang der energiewende
wie wir sie sehen in der welt mit
erneuerbaren energien stand deutschland
es stand politischer wille und
politische subventionen für neue
technologien die diese technologien
weltweit zu den billigsten gemacht haben
und das fehlt mir bis jetzt in diese
diskussion noch etwas von der von der
philosophischen und eigenen moralischen
verantwortung wenn die wieder einen
demokratie leben haben wir auch eine
politische moralische verantwortung und
dort einzusetzen
und da würde ich gerne ein bisschen mehr
hören auch in bezug auf den flugverkehr
weil hier gibt es vor allem für die
schweiz ganz einfache sachen die wir
machen könnten
ein stichwort darauf einstimmig wurde
zum beispiel dass flüge sind einfach
steuer befreit von mehrwertsteuer und
von der mineralölsteuer wenn sie mit dem
auto tanken sollen sie etwa 60 prozent
des preises ist nur eine steuer das ist
ein einfaches beispiel es gibt noch mehr
vielen anderen
bei uns ist auch matthias möhrle aber
personalchef der schlüssel bis zum
grounding und ist heute in verschiedenen
funktionen tätig unter anderem
verwaltungsrat der bälle airlines was
sagen sie zu dem was da gerade der
floriani gesagt hat sie sagen ich weiß
von ihm sie sagen fliegen ist großartig
müsse es ja was sagen sie sind ein
großer flugschein infiziert mit dem
virus sagen sie aber gleichzeitig sagen
sie auch wir müssen die persönliche
verantwortung wahrnehmen trifft auf
etwas von dem was florian eckl sagt er
ist korrekt wir müssen uns bewusst sein
was wir was wir tun müssen unserer
unserer wirkung die wir haben
bewusstsein kam eine familie ist jetzt
eine pflegefamilie ich bin pfleger und
ich mag das pflegen einfach aber was wir
tun hat ja auch alle konsequenzen und
ich muss mir überlegen wofür ist es gut
fliege ich um spaß zu haben fliege ich
um andere menschen kennenzulernen fliege
ich um mit anderen menschen in kontakt
zu treten pflege ich um zu anderen
menschen vertrauen aufzubauen sodass
gibt verschiedene motivation und ich
glaube das ist das der punkt wenn man
davon ausgeht dass die die motivation
zum fliegen immer gleich ist und dass
dem die moralische legitimation immer
gleich ist da kommt man nicht weiter so
müssen überlegen was von dem fliegen ist
sinnvoll was bringt uns als menschheit
weiter die digitalisierung dass sie
haben völlig recht dass das jetzt nicht
die lösung aller probleme ist sondern
sie kreiert neue dinge die strukturen
die wir haben eine digitalisierung sind
ausschließlich oder fast ausschließlich
auf zusammenarbeit angelegt und
zusammenarbeit kann ich nur mit jemandem
den ich vertraue vertrauen kann ich nur
an ihn kenne also wir müssen mehr
miteinander in dialog treten und brocken
fliegen
genau das verstehe ich vielleicht können
wir diskutieren für gewisse reisen jetzt
würde ich aber sie gerne doch auch
fragen beim menschen infizierte mit dem
flug virus dann müssten sie ja jetzt
nach dem was sie gesagt haben
trotzdem zugestehen einfach so in die
ferien fliegen wenn ich auch ferien
machen kann den schweizer alpen liegt da
ja eigentlich nicht trinken ja gut nach
ihren eigentlichen zu verändern
schweizer alpen und ich bin ich liebe
diesen leuten nein natürlich nicht dass
ich sage die verantwortung muss jeder
selber bahnen gut kommen wir noch einmal
zum geradestehen zurück watch and i net
dass sie haben noch ein stichwort
erwähnt dass ich noch mal aufnehmen
möchte ich habe nämlich gesagt auf
diesen teller mit in salat wenn ich
danach fords bild noch mal blühen darf
da liegen ja nicht nur unterschiedliche
zahlen sondern auch unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten was wir tun können
fleischverzicht ist etwas was immer
wieder genannt wird
sie haben aber auch die kinder genannt
und tatsächlich ist es ja so dass kinder
zu haben
relativ gravierend einschenkt ich kann
ihnen sagen wer zwei kinder hat der 500
mal weniger den atlantik überqueren als
die anderen
wenn man das gerne tun möchte und der
club of rome hat ja vorgeschlagen allen
frauen die bis zum fünfzigsten
lebensjahr maximal ein kind geboren
haben eine prämie zu bezahlen von 80.000
us dollar also kinder in die welt zu
setzen scheint der größte beitrag zu
sein für einen negativen für negatives
klima ergebnis was machen wie
philosophisch damit sollen wir jetzt
eine andere auch noch dass kinder haben
verbieten aber der charme dieses
vorschlags liegt natürlich darin dass er
absolut ins schwarze trifft weil wir als
mensch natürlich die größten und die
einzigen umweltsünder sind und wenn wir
uns entscheiden uns nicht mehr vor
pflanzen dann rocken wir uns selber aus
und damit ist das problem in einer
generation gelöst ich sag das jetzt
absichtlich so übertrieben weil es den
diesen vorschlag auch für sehr
übertrieben halte ich selbst habe keine
kinder ich habe am anfang gesagt wir
fliegen nicht in die ferien also mit
diesen zwei elementen ist mein
fußabdruck völlig in ordnung und ich
brauche mir über nichts mehr gedanken zu
machen ist doch eigentlich bin ich fein
raus ich glaube wir sind die einzigen
beiden hier am tisch die kinder haben
uns abdruck ist ziemlich schlecht
ja ja und es ist natürlich wirklich ein
absolut absurder vorschlag der davon
club of rome kommt und es ist natürlich
das würde jetzt ein ganz anderes fass
aufmachen radikales ökologisches denken
ist in der tat menschenfeindlich und
führt am ende tatsächlich sagen wir mal
zu seiner form von öko faschismus ist
eine vollkommen absurde idee dass das
was eigentlich leben ausmacht
ja wie zb also enger beziehungen zu
haben oder dinge zu tun die nicht
instrumenteller logik unterliegen die
einfach nur so sind weisen eine qualität
in sich selber haben dass man das unter
ort dritt unter kriterien wie co2
emissionen und sonst was diese bezahlen
dinge angeht und genau daraus würde ich
ein argument machen
das ist ganz viel stärker gerade in
dieser gegenwart in unserer hoch
luxuriösen gegenwart darauf ankommt noch
mal auf den prüfstand zu stellen was
denn eigentlich wirklich die elementaren
qualitäten von leben sind die haben
nämlich mit der steigerung logik
ziemlich wenig zu tun dass es seit
200.000 jahren ziemlich konstant
menschen möchten was essen die möchten
was trinken und sie möchten geliebt
werden und dazu gibt es bestimmte medien
und die sind nicht sozusagen besser wenn
es immer mehr von allem gibt ja ich bin
sicher das stimmt einerseits mit der
steigung logik andererseits ist nicht so
faszinierender für menschen
offensichtlich als diese steigerungs
logik und zwar auf allen ebenen übrigens
auch die ebene der kinder und das ist
genau einer problematischen punkt der
ähnliches kann nette hat mal die
menschen als vermehrungsrate beschrieben
wir wollen immer mehr werden ja es
spricht er niemandem das recht staat
diese urtümlichen lebens betätigungen
der gattung zu vollziehen und sich zu
vermehren
aber warum das seit einiger zeit so
hinauf geht die kurve
ja und die sozusagen ehrt population
sich in den letzten jahrzehnten
vervielfacht hat
das ist eine logik die nicht sein müsste
und es wäre auch vollkommen sinnlos zu
leugnen dass die ökologischen probleme
die probleme des klimas die probleme des
ressourcenverbrauchs die probleme der
energie andere sind wenn drei milliarden
menschen auf der erde leben oder wenn
zwölf milliarden menschen auf der erde
leben alles andere ist plant geologie
also kann man schon darüber nachdenken
und wird auch darüber nachgedacht wie
man so sagen diese form des
bevölkerungswachstums einigermaßen in
den griff bekommt das interessante ist
dass die entwickelten regionen die
ohnehin sozusagen wenig kinder
produzieren wie mitteleuropa nordeuropa
und nordamerika kletterten
sind ja meisten ressourcen verbrauchen
also das ist auch eine logik die nicht
ganz stimmig ist dramatisch jetzt
natürlich wenn die kinderreichen
populationen ebenfalls in diesen
ressourcenverbrauchs zyklus einsteigen
und es dann so oder so eng wird die
folgen wären wir natürlich alle spüren
und wenn es dann zu spät gewesen sein
wird wenn man dann lange in
philosophische stammtischen darüber
diskutieren wer jetzt eigentlich seine
verantwortung hätte wahrnehmen müssen
aber nicht wahr genommen habt und das
sogar noch so vorhanden sind werden auch
sagen aber habt ihr euch eigentlich
nichts dabei gedacht was wir getan hat
da würde ich gerne zurück zur
politischen verantwortung die ihnen am
herzen liegt gentinetta sie haben ja
vorhin den vorschlag gehört von herrn
egli wären sie eigentlich aus liberal
denkende politik philosophie der meinung
wir sollten diese ganze geschichte jetzt
regeln die ja eine steuer wie der
vorschlag von kam also ganz
grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen man kann
solche solche probleme für verschiedene
wege lösen wir haben einerseits in
preisanreize das heißt wir versuchen
etwas stärker zu bepreisen einen höheren
preis zu gehen das heißt wir führen
beispielsweise eine steuer ein
beim fliegen ich musste mich da auch
schlau machen dass es tatsächlich
interessant und es ist für die schweiz
besonders interessant ich bin jetzt
wieder ironisch muss man manchmal
anmelden damit auch so verstanden wird
besteuert werden nämlich nur inlandflüge
jetzt stellen sie sich mal vor wie viel
ihnen dann flüge es in der schweiz gibt
also ich weiss kommt da besonders weg
ich weitere überhaupt keine interesse
dieses dieses diese steuer zu erhöhen
die usa sind beispielsweise schon anders
aus das heißt international wert das
fliegen nicht besteuert war es ja
angesetzt sich der internationalität des
fliegens wirklich eigentlich absurd ist
dieser vertrag stammt von 1944 offenbar
bis jetzt keine handhabe gefunden den zu
ändern es müssten nämlich alle zustimmen
und dass es wie immer das problem mit
einer internationalen ebene also bevor
nicht alle zustimmen macht niemand den
ersten schritt valverde erster werden
ersten schritt macht derzeit sozusagen
den kürzeren
also müsste man quasi wirklich dass wir
arbeiten aber eben auf allen
internationalen ebenen und lernen nicht
den den punkt aufnehmen von florian egli
dann könnte man ja sagen na ja das ist
einmal so der
elegante muss dass man sagt ich einfach
ein politisches problem aber er hat ja
recht wenn er sagt dahinter ist
natürlich die moralische frage was geht
uns das eigentlich an zumal in einer
direkten demokratie hier drin sitzen
lauter personen die ihr stimmrecht ich
würde schon noch unterscheiden zwischen
einem moralischen problem also man das
wesen der demokratie und des
rechtsstaats liegt ja darin dass sie
nicht jedes moralische problem in ein
gesetz zu gießen
das heißt irgendwo müssen eine grenze
ziehen und sagen wo es etwas wirklich so
strafbar was wir es im gesetz haben
wollen und müssen und dass auch familien
und irgendwo sind die appelle und
dazwischen müssen wir mit gescheiten
regelungen das könne neben preise seien
oder kontingente anreize ich erinner nur
noch kurz an den gegenwärtigen
nobelpreisträger ökonomie der mit den
nazis eben mit diesen anreizen phase
operiert also wie können wir wie können
wir bessere entscheide quasi entscheiden
die richtige richtung lenken
das ist eine diffizile sache die aber
politisch gelöst werden muss wir sind
fast am schluss unserer diskussion herr
ließ man was möchten sie dazu noch rein
möchte sagen also das war mein erster
vorschlag dass wir preise zu regeln und
preis heißt natürlich über steuersysteme
das zu regulieren und das machen wir in
allen anderen bereichen auch es ist es
nicht so dass es keine steuern gebe für
andere dinge die vielleicht nicht das
sind als fliegen ehrlich gesagt das ist
das eine
und das zweite ist also natürlich ist es
auch eine frage der politik und des
politischen willen sollte das
durchzusetzen wenn uns das klima so
wichtig ist wie alle tun da muss es doch
möglich sein
treibstoffe die flugverkehr verbraucht
seien verbraucht ein genauso zu
besteuern und zu bepreisen wie für den
autoverkehr und ich weiß jetzt nicht
verboten ist so was furchtbares überall
sind wir umzingelt von verboten und
niemand regt sie hoffen jetzt norwegen
paris oxford diesel-fahrzeuge verbieten
mittlerweile ist das selbstverständlich
so schnell kann es gehen warum das
fliegende emotional so besetzt ist
verständlich nicht alle überall arbeite
mit steuern mit preisen und mit verboten
wenn es uns darum geht politische ziele
zu erreichen von denen ich weiß ich kann
sie nicht erreichen wenn ich sie
wirklich zusammen zur moralischen
problem herunter definiere und
entscheidendes einzelnen überlassen wird
wenig passieren außer dass die bahn
inhalt dann auf den free aufs fliegen
verzichten ein gutes gewissen haben
schlusswort noch zu diesem thema
eigenverantwortung politik wie teilen
wir die problematik auf dafür teilen sie
nicht auf sondern die eigenverantwortung
wird erst an der stelle interessant wo
sie in einem gesamtrahmen stattfindet
der sich auch verantwortlich verhalten
kann so und das ist eigentlich eine
relativ eigene geschichte oder einfache
geschichte das ist ohne politische
regulierung ohne ordnungspolitik nicht
geht die aber nicht passieren wird so
lange sich die menschen kollektiv
unverantwortlich verhalten und sagen die
politik muss es regeln da muss von unten
entsprechend auch protest und initiative
und so kommen
ich frage sie zum schluss wer von ihnen
im raum wird aufgrund der debatte die
wir geführt haben
auf einen flug verzichten kommenden jahr
ein paar wenige es ist ihnen unbenommen
selber zu entscheiden ob sie die
argumente der flug gegner und
gegnerinnen nicht überzeugt haben oder
was auch immer sich dazu überlegt haben
auf jeden fall sind wir am ende unserer
sendung am ende unseres gesprächs ich
habe gestern in einer buchhandlung diese
postkarte hier gefunden darauf steht
nachher hatten und immer recht man
sollte gleich nachher leben und günter
eich
ich bin mal gespannt wie nachher dann
ist nach dem klimawandel jetzt ist
erstmal nach der sendung ich danke ihnen
ganz ganz herzlich für das
mitdiskutieren
ich danke ihnen allen fürs kommen für
ihr interesse und ich danke ihnen auch
zu hause ganz herzlich fürs zuschauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]